i was um i've been playing a lot of
cyberpunk man
fun game i gotta say it's a lot it's
look i get that it's got glitches but
it's a lot of fun my favorite is the
people that complain about
games having bugs and you're like when
when has there ever been a game that was
just
absolutely perfect on launch um what is
there everybody getting
i mean it's perfect ever since we've
ever since companies have had the
option to update patches online there
hasn't been no they just rush it out
everything i'll fix it later
because i mean you think of other games
that came out before that that you're
like oh like that's like
you know goldeneye you know like there
was you couldn't update that you
couldn't patch it like that game had to
come out good
like that's how the game had to come out
you know yeah nowadays you just
you just you basically pay 60 bucks to
be a beta tester anyway
[ __ ] betas beta i'm an alpha tester
bro
i walk in and i bully all the beta
testers i'm like bro i'm doing gaming
is that how they uh is that basically
what the system is at these game
companies i didn't know that i didn't
know the out
so the alphas are the jocks of the
tester yeah the alpha testers okay
what's up and then there's and then
there's the gammas
and then i know this i remember vox day
taught me this
he did he did very slowly with a lot of
pauses um
remember those commercials that were on
g4 tv
like the ones that they tried to sell
kids into going into like
game development to make it look cool oh
of course
those worth of you want a career in
video games and it's like this is not
they came on right after the everest
college commercials
oh you want a game dude this is totally
cool when in real life it's just playing
the same level
over and over and over again trying to
hit every wall
touch everything and that's the thing
it's not even playing the game
it's like okay so check it out i need
you to walk in a zigzag pattern
throughout this dungeon for four hours
don't swing your sword
don't kill anything that pops up you
just walk
we need to see how the walking physics
are and it's just in hours of
or it's literally all right like it's
like when you do like there's got to be
guys that tested for rust that are like
all right you get a rock stand in front
of this tree
and just keep hitting trees and you're
like really yeah for hours and see if
there's any tree bugs and you're like
that's they made you stay made it sound
like we're playing video games and it's
like no you're testing
testing sucks ty's aquarius washington
says want a job even an indian wouldn't
take
but remember how cool this this is the
old with your commercials
oh hurry up man boss is coming in dude
almost got it okay question you've
played video game back in the day you
played two-player games with people
right
did you literally sit on your buddy's
lap like i did it every commercial used
to do this back in the day and i'm like
why are you embracing each other i know
why
maybe the regular nintendo because they
were so short
four by three this is back in the four
by three day and you had to fit them
both in frame
that way you wouldn't have to pay for a
multi-camera shoot that's the reason
the real reason i almost got it
hey guys finished testing that game yet
i've got another one i need designs
wait a minute so they have a woman boss
at this game company
apparently i bet that game sucks game's
got to be
terrible can we make everyone including
sarkeesian as your boss oh god gaming
company uh really
women with breasts like really
after she leaves that gig hey why does
your mom keep talking like she's our
boss it's [ __ ] weird
she literally though i i love i love
sarkisian because she just doesn't even
bother with
like she doesn't even like her arguments
are so ridiculous at this point that
it's literally just oh my god female
characters
that have breasts that are pretty like
you can tell it's just internalized
self-hate like with her she she thinks
she feels ugly
so every time she sees a uh she's ugly
yeah every time she sees a video game
character that's pretty she's like
oh my god pretty girls with boobs women
makeup
kits oh god this is ridiculous
it's such a ridiculous standard and it's
like what to just
shower and have nice boobs it's not even
that but she lost her mind about the
mandalorian
arm female armor having tits and it's
like well even women were like
you know we have tits right like they
have to fit in armor like did you see
how many people sent her links to all
the new body armor oh yeah yeah
literally they're making because they're
used to not be as many
women in the field now there's a lot of
women cops a lot of women
they've now started designing uh
vests and plate carriers for women that
aren't crazy different but they just you
know to give you a little more uh
give you a little more room in the tit
region and i don't think that's a
scientific term but i hear what you're
saying
it is i if i was given the presentation
i'd get a lot of clients all right
ladies and gentlemen the future of tit
protection
like the thing comes down and the lights
open up like like one of those [ __ ]
ridiculous techniques like steve jobs
ladies and gentlemen i bring you the
future in tit protection
and like some orchestral score plays and
everybody's like
ooh and then like a podium comes up
through the stage
and it doesn't even have the body armor
it's just a set of tits
it's just titties are we gonna see any
armor in this presentation
sir we'll get to that first the tits
but yeah though so you have this you
have to start it with like you know ever
since the dawn of man
and start touching the tits you know for
many many years
it was mostly men who came to your house
and shot your dog
but today i bring you the future of law
enforcement
women who shoot unarmed minorities and
everybody's just like yay
here at t-tech
tech we've merged with armor co
so now we're just really it's great
because now we have two teams
different sets of expertise and we're
working together to streamline and
create synergy
to protect your tits from ballistic
weapons
so this is a we lost our point here
sorry sorry we were doing comedy it's
called a bit
it's it you know what mike i don't think
people like when we were
i don't give a [ __ ] i do comedy it's fun
bits are fun
when are you going to start we just did
the tit thing
that was funny that wasn't real oh my
jesus christ 734 episodes i've been
taking everything you're saying
literally yeah no it's just bits folks
holy [ __ ] that's a relief that is a
relief
dude because i was like we can't fund
this tit company mike we don't have the
money
yeah we do to fund a tick company yes to
tit armor company you don't [ __ ] pay
for itself dude
[ __ ] kidding me he's gonna pay for
itself
i mean okay the presentation alone is
gonna cost like 2.8 mil but
if we you know what i mean once we get
through that you know and then okay so
our burn rate is like maybe
two months tops but we'll get some money
together all right we'll figure it out
almost got it hey guys finished testing
that game yet
i've got another one i need designed
shut up you stupid
don't [ __ ] tell me where to live my
life what i don't get what i don't
understand is so uh
they're also the ones who design the
games yeah they do both
and also what kind of timeline are you
working with that you're just you only
have two guys working for you and they
got to test the game and then start
working on the new game
that's not how it works and the other
thing is what kind of testing facility
doesn't have actual like a sofa or
something for them
so here's what happened whoever did this
film this at the reception center of
their place
and they're like just i can sit on the
desk i guess sit on the desk and you
know game test
actual game testers they're usually not
in an office actual game testers work
from home
and they get a beta copy of the game and
they do it from home
and they basically have a github and
they keep [ __ ] details and they go oh
yeah when i touched this wall the whole
game crashed
you know when i interacted with this
item this happened but like i just love
too that she comes in there's just two
guys and she's like are you done testing
by the way the the dialogue's so generic
are you done testing that game yet we
have to design another one and it's like
but that's not how a game company works
you could design another one with this
one's going on i'd already have writers
going okay so for the next game
we're going to go medieval fantasy i'm
going gonna go turn-based strategy
i've got and while there's dudes in
another room testing the game that's
already rolling out
like this whole thing is just whoever
gave your money to these companies i
have to laugh at you
hey guys finish testing that game yet
i've got another one i need designed
we just finished level three and need to
tighten up the graphics a little bit
that is not out that is some rob from
pardemic level acting by the way
that is some rob from burden and rob
from level writing nct software
just have to finish level three and then
what what are you why are you talking
like that
again that is not out game game testing
is okay royce
you you have one job we've usually
nowadays especially the bigger companies
there's like
a hundred testers they'll have one guy
where it's like your only
job is physics i want you to just keep
going out and getting killed
and getting hit by cars and then just
write down where your body goes and how
it's very boring work but it's not like
we need you to play all the levels
just play through one time and if it
works then we'll just release the game
what is this what do they look like
bethesda
great hey i can't
hey i want to [ __ ] your mom that's your
mom right i totally want to [ __ ] your
mom
this is this is the bethesda testing
office
hey does she know that we don't actually
really test anything and we just submit
fake reports all the time
i'm working on a tit mod for skyrim what
do you mean tester [ __ ]
dude let the customers do it yeah that's
it if they have a problem with the game
they'll let us know
we'll patch it in six months like we
normally do uh yeah
dude we got uh our our content
department dude woody tell them
dude tell them to meet us for lunch
we're gonna go party yeah but they said
they had to design some more
that's what modders are for to make
clothes for the game
hey i can't believe we got jobs doing
this i know
and my mom said i would never get
anywhere with these games
and also also you mind if i stay at your
place tonight my mom will let me come
home
also this idea that grown men are at
work and the first thing they talk about
is their mom
yeah no one know who would
these commercials were meant to take
money from young dumb people
that's exactly what they were designed
for and they were also just
so tone-deaf yeah my mom said i would
have never gotten anywhere with video
games
call westwood college online
800-914-8582
that's 914. notice it's not intended for
residents of texas or
massachusetts yeah because they have
consumer protection laws
that is correct planning missions
outside by the way can i just say
something i just typed in
westwood college and it auto filled
royce would you like to know what the
cam lawsuit
ah i was so close same thing
but still very funny i didn't type in
anything else just westwood college
space and
lawsuit then eliminate
them it's what i was programmed to do
discographically designed and you could
create characters
cyberpunk looks pretty good i'll be
honest with you like me
and this world i'm trying to save the
game industry
is booming oh here we go westwood
college was founded in 1986 as a
for-profit higher education institution
also i want to stop calling these
predatory companies for-profit education
okay
all education is for profit education
i'm tired of hearing this
you're right tired of being here i'm
tired of being told that that
institutes of high learning that's
accredited and is an ivy league college
isn't a [ __ ]
like like you're not making young black
guys go out and run the football
break their neck and then not even pay
them like you know what i mean like stop
it you're all for profit
you guys charge like 200 bucks for a
[ __ ]
math book that somebody that's used
and then when you go back to the end of
the year to sell it back they give you
like 78 cents for it
stop telling me you're not for profit
you you guys roll out
billions of dollars all right well we
could uh
oh it's closed yeah it's not open on
november 12 2015 westworld susp
west world westworld west well
west world got closed down too they had
a lot of problems there
uh westwood suspended all enrollment
citing poor enrollment and new
government regulations
on january 25th 2016 uh the school sent
out an email to current former students
advising him that all westwood college
will be closing its doors in march after
the conclusion of the january 2016 term
so i guess apparently the the laws were
pot like they were getting so many
lawsuits and [ __ ] people were just
grossed out by it